most people number one they get up in
the morning the first thing they do is
they think about the problems in their
life and those problems are memories
from the past so the moment they think
about their problems they're thinking in
the past every one of those problems has
an emotion attached to them so they
start feeling unhappy or unworthy or
whatever and how you think and how you
feel is your state of being so most
people's entire state of being is in the
past when they start today so within the
familiar past they're going to live in a
predictable future right so they get up
and they check their cell phone they
check the text their WhatsApp their
Facebook they post something on Facebook
they tweet they Twitter they check the
news and they go to the bathroom get a
cup of coffee take a shower get dressed
check more emails drive to work the same
way do the same thing so I'm going to
program they've actually lost their free
will to the program wow so if you start
your day with this simple question what
is the greatest ideal of myself that I
can be today ask yourself that question
now listen your body's going to go like
well we got to get a cup of coffee and
you got to go body you're not the mind
I'm the mind right now you're gonna sit
here I'm gonna feed you this is my time
you're going to obey me the body's no
longer the mind you're the mind and so
when it wants to get up and you become
aware of it and turn back to the present
moment every time you do that's a
victory and changing some aspect of
yourself need motivation watch your top
10 with believe Nation hey it's hey it's
Evan Carl Michael and I make these
videos because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best Dr Joe dispenza and my take
on his top 10 rules of success enjoy
ask yourself I do this all the time
write down four thoughts that you're
going to stay conscious of the whole day
I can't it's too hard you'd be surprised
the moment you become conscious of what
those thoughts are how unconscious
you've been to them all day you know for
weeks on end write down what you speak
how you speak four things you want to
change how you act
how do you how do you act do you
complain do you blame you make excuses
you feel sorry for yourself that's a
victim Consciousness what emotions do
you live by is it possible that you're
so used to living by guilty don't even
know it's guilt it just feels like you
do you allow your energy to drop become
conscious of those states of mind and
body and review them and say this is the
old self then say
what thoughts do I want to fire and wire
in my brain and start firing and wiring
and start feeling it what behaviors will
I demonstrate today what choices will I
make one day one Lifetime and just like
you did rehearse them rehearse the whole
entire thing begin to install the
neurological Hardware in your brain and
if you keep installing it the hardware
is going to become a software program
and you start thinking and act in that
way and then here's the tough part
can you teach your body emotionally
what your future is going to feel like
before it's made manifest and don't get
up until you feel that way rule number
two always keep learning I think the
first thing is to learn every time you
learn you make new Connections in your
brain and learning is making those
connections and I was joking with my
staff this week I said nobody reads
anymore nobody reads nobody reads
anything learn information why because
we found out
that in our events if you can be present
and not look at your cell phone or not
talk about your past but be present with
the content and I can combine quantum
physics with Neuroscience with
neuroendocrinology with
psychoneuroimmunology Mind Body
Connection epigenetics electromagnetism
you can really get it like you can give
me the nod and then I say okay you I
look at an audience of 1500 600 people
okay well turn to the person next to you
and teach it back to them if you can't
explain that um
it's not wired in your brain and you'll
doubt that it's possible and you'll do
something differently okay if you can
explain it then you're causing your
brain to fire in new sequences and new
patterns and new combinations whenever
you make your brain work differently
you're changing your mind why
his mind is the brain in action so you
keep reminding yourself in this now this
it's easier to forget this than remember
it you know it takes practice it really
you can't get it in one bite it's a
learning process right so now you're
installing the neurological Hardware in
your brain in preparation for the
experience so knowledge is the precursor
to the experience right without the
knowledge and the information it's
conjecturous right so the more you
understand the what in the terms of what
you're doing and the why you're doing it
the application the Practical aspect the
how becomes exciting like oh I'm going
to get it as an example you can take
someone and throw them in an ice bath
we have no knowledge advice but what
that can do and then because I have no
knowledge the ice path is actually gonna
is going to cost them harm right right
you take that person you can teach them
a few things and put them in a nice bath
and actually be instrumental actually
gain value from it well the prefrontal
cortex the one that said now you got to
make this you got to make this valuable
you can take a person
and you can you can put them in an
environment and they can perceive the
environment as a problem and you can
measure their autonomic response and
it'll weaken their autonomic response
you can take that person and have them
perceive it as a challenge and it'll
actually strengthen their autonomic
response okay so now what's the what's
what's the reason behind this well you
gotta you gotta put as much tension on
your inner world
of how you're thinking and how you're
feeling and how you're going to behave
as much as your outer world of
three-dimensional reality and meditation
is just a way to say okay let me get my
brain and body right I'm going to
present Ed mylett to the world today I
got one lifetime one groundhog day one
day
I just want something different
something unusual something mystical
some sign from the universe that I
created and I wanted to come in a way
that I would never think of that would
be the unknown because if I can predict
it it's the known okay let me before I
get up and grab my phone
and do all my things and get plugged
back into my Known World let me just say
okay who do I no longer want to be I
want to become so conscious that I won't
go unconscious again the fundamental
question is how many times
am I going to forget until I stop
forgetting and start remembering that is
the moment there's nothing mystical
about this
this is the work
and then you're going to say okay who do
I want to be when I open my eyes okay
let me think about this how would
greatness left I don't know read a book
on greatness read a book on Nelson
Mandela you want to be wealthy read
about wealthy people and you're going to
see that they didn't just make their
wealth they lost a ton of money and
failed them a million times it was and
that's reality okay well let's what what
were the qualities that were they had
perseverance they had determination they
let they cut their losses they forgave
they forgot about it they went on okay
so how am I going to behave let me
rehearse how I'm going to behave
I'm gonna do me take my time I have I
have plenty of time to do let me just
behave let me think about how I'm going
to behave differently in this situation
how am I going to change my emotional
response when did I fall from grace
yesterday and went back to my old self
let me just I'll set up I'll set an
alarm on my phone every three hours I'm
gonna just gonna go off and I'm gonna
take a moment and get back into the
feelings of my future okay
if I can do that over and over again
well what what do you think could happen
in my life as a result of it so
knowledge being the Forerunner the
application simple stuff simple stuff
practice hard coherence there's plenty
of stuff that we can you know we can
talk about practice brain coherence it's
we know we know I asked the brain
scientists what percentage of people at
the end of a week-long event uh what
percentage of people will have their
brains changed for the better they said
100 100 one week fully immersed in into
the experience you practice it every day
now
you can do it once or twice and say why
isn't my bank account full you know what
I'm going to tell you you're not that
good yeah that's the only reason why if
you were that good it would happen
you're not that good so show up again
and show up again and keep showing up
and I just was talking to a staff member
today the universe only gives us what we
think we're worthy of receiving right so
then people who show up for themselves
every day I believe they're worthy they
they start feeling pretty damn worthy
like hey they're like I'm worthy for
this not like an entitlement way like
something or are they just like I'm I'm
really I'm real I feel like it's gonna
happen I'm worthy for it rule number
three change your inner State I learned
a lot about expectation when I was
studying uh the placebo uh you know it's
amazing how you can give someone a sugar
pill or a saline injection or perform
some false surgery or treatment
and a certain percentage of those people
will accept believe and surrender to the
thought
that it's actually the truth without
analyzing it that they're getting an
actual real substance and their body
begins to manufacture the very Pharmacy
of chemicals
that causes them to heal by thought
alone so the question is is it the you
know inert exogenous substance that's
doing the healing or is it the body's
innate capacity to heal so so everybody
has been conditioned to a certain degree
whether we like it or not to rely on
something outside of us
to change our inner State and and and so
when a person's given a pill and it's
and it's blue on one side and red on the
other and they take it and they notice a
change in their internal State my pain
has gone away uh I'm sleeping better
whatever it is
and when they notice that change in
their internal State they pay attention
to what caused it and they start to
associate and condition so well if you
keep doing that over and over again
uh that pill uh becomes a symbol of them
to change their physiology so if you
take that pill and you replace it with
something that's a nerd and they see
that pill based on conditioning when
they take that pill conditioning based
on the past they begin to expect
that outcome to happen again and the
expectation of the outcome is simply
marrying a a possibility an intention a
vision of a future outcome a new
possibility in the quantum field
and if the doctor's enthusiastic and you
name the substance something that you
can't pronounce and you charge a lot of
money for it and you use a name that
rhymes with something that could
actually you could associate as a known
uh you know Niagara and Viagra there's a
strong correlation it's a lot of flow
and and so people are conditioned to
expect an outcome so
when they start to expect the outcome
the marrying of that clear intention if
the person is optimistic if the person
is enthusiastic if the person is uh uh
grateful for the outcome a combination
of that clear intention combined with
the elevated emotion
begins to change the body's physiology
for them to manufacture their own
Pharmacy of antidepressants their own
Pharmacy of morphines are pain relievers
their own Pharmacy of dopamine by
thought alone so the question is do you
need the exogenous substance to change
your state of being or can you change
your state of being by thought alone
and by the same means if you give a
person a prognosis and you tell them
that in the chemotherapy treatments you
are going to get really nauseous and
sick they've done research on this fifty
percent of the people on their Drive
to the chemos that herpe treatment start
to get nauseous in anticipation of the
event taking place so the question is
can 50 of the people get well on their
drive to work or they're on their drive
to their doctor and anticipation in
anticipation of getting the right
treatment in your studies with the power
of eight
if the person can assign meaning
to the value of what they're doing and
they can see oh my God energy can
actually inform matter okay that sounds
like something that makes sense give me
the quantum understanding
and you get a collective group of people
and we're discovering that Collective
networks of Observers
determine reality and you can get them
in a very specific State and the person
who's receiving the healing understands
the the value of what's taking place
the expectation of what's about to
happen if they're in a state of
gratitude it's kind of an interesting
thing gratitude when we receive
something when we've just received
something favorable when something's
happening to us that we really enjoy or
something just happened to us that
surprises us we feel gratitude so the
emotional signature of gratitude is
something's happening to us or something
favorable just happened to it it is the
ultimate state that we receive in
so if the person's in that state of
gratitude then it makes sense then
they're more susceptible to information
because we accept believe and surrender
to information equal to our emotional
state so that can actually program the
autonomic nervous system to begin to
physiologically change and that's
exactly what Pavlov did with the
salivating dogs just ring the bell and
feed them a meal and after a while the
anticipation
of the event actually causes them to
change their body's physiology their
autonomic nervous system begins to
change as if they're actually in the
process of eating the meal the
anticipation is preparing for the event
ahead of time and we can use that to so
many degrees uh in our favor rule number
four reprogram your brain the hormones
of stress push the genetic buttons that
create disease if you can turn on the
stress response just by thought alone
your thoughts could make you sick and if
your thoughts could make you sick is it
possible that your thoughts could make
you well so they began to realize that
oh my God the repetition of thinking and
feeling and feeling and thinking caused
me to feel guilt and I don't even know
it's guilt it just feels like me it's
just I'm used to the same chemical
continuity now the moment they decided
to change anytime you decide to change
and change anything about yourself get
ready because it's going to feel
uncomfortable you're going to leave The
Gnome yeah you're gonna leave the
familiar and you're gonna step into the
unknown even if the familiar is
uncomfortable and painful right you're
still going to be painful leaving the
pain right because some people are super
happy being unhappy right so then they
would rather cling to their suffering
than take a chance and possibility so
these people said I really have nothing
to lose right
so then they said I'm willing to be
uncomfortable and be in the unknown and
it turns out that's the perfect place to
create from so when the body is
conditioned to become the mind then to
change is to be greater than the body
right because we become greater than the
body well that's a whole nother
conversation but let me finish this okay
so the third thing they said was
okay so now that I know that I got to
break the habit of being myself and I
can't mismanage my thoughts and feelings
I got to change how I act I got to watch
how I speak I gotta become conscious of
how unconscious I am because 95 percent
of Who We Are by the time we're 35 years
old it's a set of memorized behaviors
like a computer program emotional
reactions unconscious beliefs and
perceptions so the first step to change
is to become conscious of how you think
to notice how you act to pay attention
to how you feel and the act of observing
those states of Mind and Body separates
you from that program now you're you're
you're the Consciousness observing that
program it turns out the more conscious
you become of how unconscious you are
you know letting imagine a dark place
that first step creates enormous amounts
of Chaos in the brain and body and it's
disturbing so people just go back to the
same addiction the same emotion the same
problem just feels better no that feels
familiar so they said okay now I'm not
going to change I gotta reinvent myself
now this is really important because
they started sitting down and thinking
Okay who in history do I admire we're
great people role models that I can
follow what are the qualities and
characteristics that they have how am I
going to change you know these are what
we call frontal lobe questions the
creative center of the brain switches on
an emotional Center settles down
so then they started thinking
I have to be in a new life if I was
really going to heal what would I have
to change about myself
now there's this interesting phenomenon
that if you close your eyes and you
begin to think about doing something
you're an athlete you understand this if
you're a background in football and you
are running a pattern or you are doing
something you would rehearse it in your
mind turns out
that the act of mentally rehearsing
something when you're truly present
your brain does not know the difference
between what's going on out there and
what's going on in here in fact your
brain will begin to look like you've
been doing it for the last five days and
you've never run the course so now your
brain is no longer a record of the past
because typically it is now it's a map
to the Future so now you're priming your
brain so that became the very platform
you know experiments with piano players
you know you take a group of people that
never played the piano before you divide
them into two different categories
I think one group of people you teach
them one-handed scales and chords you do
a brain scan on them they come in
practice for two hours a day for five
days at the end of five days if you
rescan the brain they grow new circuits
on the opposite side of the brain
nothing magical there you learn
something new learning's making new
connections get some instruction you get
instruction you get your body involved
get your body involved you're gonna have
an experience experience in which is the
brain pay attention to what you're doing
you got to pay attention and repeat it
firing and wiring you're going to
assemble new circuits you can take the
other group of people have them come for
two hours a day for five days do a brain
scan before the brain scan after have
them close their eyes and mentally
rehearse playing those scales and chords
at the end of five days they'll grow the
same amount of circuits and their brain
as the people who actually physically
demonstrated the action what does that
mean it means not only they change their
brain by thinking differently but their
brain looks like they've been playing
the piano for five days now set them in
front of a piano never play the piano
before they'll play those scales and
chords because their brain is wired to
play it so now the act of rehearsing who
they're going to be
what are the qualities I'm beginning to
get in this creative state began to lay
down the circuits of a new personality
and a new personality is connected to a
new personal reality so the next
question is does that change the body
take a group of men have them do
one-handed
curls in their mind and bring an
emotional component like stronger harder
more intense one hour a day for two
weeks at the end of two weeks 13.5
increase in muscle strength wow never
lifted away now their body is changing
by thought Aloha so these people began
to reprogram their brain and body
and all of a sudden they began to act
differently why because they installed
the circuits they began to think
differently of course they began to feel
differently they they were no longer
feeling pain they're actually liking
themselves right so that if they're
living by a different emotion and
they're they're feeling an elevated
emotion before their healing before they
were healed they're not waiting for
their healing to feel Joy and gratitude
they're feeling gratitude and joy now
their bodies believing that it's healed
because the body's feeling the emotion
ahead of the experience if the
environment signals the Gene and the end
product of an experience in the
environment is emotion you're signaling
the gene ahead of the environment and
what do genes do genes make proteins or
what are proteins responsible the
structure and function of the body now
you're literally becoming somebody else
and now you're turning down the genes
for disease and you're turning up these
other genes so
I started to realize that this
reinvention process is exactly what
we've always done it's just that we get
complacent in certain areas of our life
and we stop also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five get Beyond yourself
let's demystify the present moment okay
people wake up in the morning and they
they think about their problems and
those problems or memories that are
etched in their brain that are connected
to certain people and objects at certain
times and places the moment they wake up
in the morning and they start thinking
of their problems they're thinking in
the past
okay now every one of those problems has
an emotion associated with it so then
they feel unhappy when they feel bitter
when they feel fearful now their bodies
in the past thoughts are the language of
the brain feelings of the language of
the body thought and a feeling image and
emotion stimulus and response you're
conditioning the body to be the mind of
that emotion subconsciously now the body
is believing it's living in the same
past experience 24 hours a day seven
days a week 365 days a year why because
the body's so objective it doesn't know
the difference between the real life
experience that's creating that emotion
and the emotion that person is created
by thought alone important the body
doesn't know the difference and so what
the environment signals the gene that's
epigenetics the end product from an
experience in the environment is an
emotion the person's signaling the same
genes in the same way and genes make
proteins and proteins are responsible
for the structure and function of your
body and the expression of proteins is
expression of life and now the person is
actually headed for a genetic Destiny
and when people labor
for the present moment
and they take their attention off of
their body off of all the people in
their life all of the objects they own
their cell phone their computer their
car their house they're no longer
identifying with where they're sitting
where they need to be where they live
where they've lived in the past where
they need to go and they're not thinking
about the predictable future of the
familiar past
they're dissociating from everything
physical and material everything known
that is the exact moment we call getting
Beyond yourself okay now
when we're in that place then at the
beginning it's uncomfortable because
we're survival is the unknown you better
chances of survival and running from the
unknown but that unknown is the perfect
place to create from so in the process
no different than any rehab in our first
two days of our event really people are
they're basically they're basically
rehabbing from their emotional states
and their habits and they're sitting in
the presence of that discomfort right
and the discomfort is because the body
is leaving the known but but but
if the body has been conditioned to be
the mind the moment you take it outside
of its familiar territory it's going to
start telling you Ed why don't you quit
you know you're not really good at this
you know you're more of a physical
person you don't really want to do this
you're not very this or very that and
most people just get up when they do
their meditation they believe that
thought as if it's true now the question
is what's on the other side of that
thought can you sit there long enough
till that's no longer the thought you
accept believe and surrender to
well then wow the next question inside
of that thought what is the other what's
on the other side of that familiar
emotion can I sit and work with my body
and settle it down stay you stay I'm
gonna feed you you're not gonna die from
this your bladder's not going to explode
you're not going to go crazy and you
work with catching those thoughts it's
called metacognition if you're in that
95 of programming where you're
unconscious
and the first step to change is becoming
conscious of your unconscious thoughts
you're so conscious that you would never
go unconscious or let that thought slip
by you unnoticed I want to understand so
you're saying the awareness of the
thought being conscious of the thought
has it somehow lose its power over you
exactly exactly because just because you
have a thought doesn't mean it's true
and if you're left alone to yourself
you'll start believing every thought you
think and that's the problem so then the
majority of people's thoughts then are
based on what they perceive about
themselves from their past or their life
right and if you catch yourself
complaining and blaming and making
excuses and judging someone else and you
say I want to be a happy person well a
happy person would never do that would
make them unhappy if you notice that
you've been feeling guilty for the last
20 years you didn't know it was guilt
because it just felt like you and you
want to feel Joy well if you can feel
Joy it should tell us volumes about what
you've been practicing doing right so
then most people give up because
they they don't know that there's
anything on the other side of it so then
the next question is
what thoughts do you want to fire and
wire in your brain well and with
attention with and with intention
if you keep practicing firing wiring
those thoughts you start installing
Hardware do it enough times and it
becomes like a software program and now
that's the new voice you program in your
head that said I can do this I believe
in myself and you've created to an
extent a new personality which can
create a new personal reality now here
we go so then the next question is how
am I going to behave with my kids today
how am I going to be with my wife I'm
going to be with my partner I'm going to
be at work I might be on my zoom calls
I'm going to be by myself how am I going
to what what does greatness look like
what is what would love do today now it
turns out that if you close your eyes
and you start imagining doing that if
you rehearse how you're going to be in
those certain situations
the evidence without a doubt shows that
your brain will start to look like
through the mental rehearsal of the act
that you've already done it now you've
installed the hardware keep doing it it
becomes a software program and you'll
start acting like a happy person no
magic there if you don't have the
circuits you can't do it so the
rehearsal then
is actually changing the brain just by
thinking differently the brain looks
like the experience has already happened
now you have Hardware to use do it
enough times you get good at it becomes
more automatic now here's the hard part
can I teach my body emotionally
what my future will feel like before it
happens now this is really important
because there's a pandemic going on in
the world that has nothing to do with a
virus that has everything to do with
people's attention span and learning
people need a rush of dopamine in order
to catch their attention or a rush of
adrenaline to learn and so that they're
they're dependent on their outer
environment to regulate their emotional
state now this is different now now I'm
going to say to you
get in that beautiful heart of yours and
I want you to feel gratitude for the
event before it occurs well I can't feel
it because it hasn't happened yet that's
the conditioning that's the hypnosis
rule number six overcome anxiety anxiety
is doing this living in the survival
when you're living in survival I'll tell
you this when the survival Gene is
activated out of the infinite Potentials
in the quantum field
you'll always choose the worst case
scenario why because if you're in
survival and you're preparing for the
worst there's always better chances of
surviving if anything less happens so
people are always selecting the worst
thing in their mind and they begin to
emotionally Embrace that future before
it happens thought and emotion you start
conditioning so you're conditioning the
body to become the mind of fear you keep
doing that enough times once the body
becomes the mind it's a subconscious
program a person has a panic attack try
as you may to control it with your
conscious mind you can't you program it
subconsciously now you worry about the
next panic attack and now as you start
worrying about the next panic attack
it's the vigilance that creates the next
one wow now here's what's happening in
our work
people who are self-regulating and
creating these elevated States we have
we have heart scans of them sustaining
hard coherence for a whole hour during a
meditation then at the end of the day
they're still wearing the monitor it's
eight o'clock at night they're not even
in a meditation and for a whole entire
hour they're in hard coherence we say to
the woman uh what's going on here she
said I have no idea I was just getting
ready for bed and all of a sudden my
heart just swelled up it was so intense
I had to lay on my back and surrender to
love WoW instead of surrendering to fear
she had a spontaneous love attack
instead of a spontaneous panic attack
now I would call that the natural state
of being so then
if you're living by those elevated
States and you know how to feel that
emotion off your future before it
happens
you're less likely to wait for it to
happen because you'll feel like it
already happened you'll less likely try
to control it you'll know that the
moment you lose the feeling you just
disconnected and you're going to make
your way back when you get good at it no
person no thing no experience can take
it away from you now you're empowered
and if you understand the laws of how
creation happens then you're less likely
to compete and rush to get what you want
you're going to know that it's going to
come to you and now that's the new model
of how we create rule number seven turn
adversity into wisdom we had a guy that
came in a wheelchair an event we did
recently
it came in that Throne he walked from he
had ALS he walked from the back of the
room all the way to the stage walked up
the stairs out of that wheelchair on his
own I asked him he said I just I just
have to work on staying in this
emotional state because the longer I
stay there the more I'm noticing that my
body's responding he's not saying why am
I why am I not healed he understands
that the only way he can actually heal
is to change him right and so now it
becomes very practical right it becomes
very practical you think it's important
that practical part of it I think
sometimes people think they're
disqualified if they can't explain
something they do well let me tell you
one of the interesting things on the
show many of the people that do things
exceptionally well that have been on my
show athletes or entertainers
really don't do a very good job of
explaining it yeah they embody it and I
think sometimes someone listens to
somebody like you who can explain this
and think that they're disqualified from
becoming good if they can't explain how
they're doing it but the truth is it's a
repeated experience that becomes
familiar for them without the need to
express how they're doing it right right
and for me right this is your this is
your life is teaching people to do this
and giving them the tools but for the
vast majority of people it's it's
creating the experience everybody
everybody has done this at least once in
their life what did they did they sat
down and they said what would it be like
to be happy what would it be like to be
healthy what would it be like to have a
new life what do we like to be in love
and they ask the question instead of
getting on their cell phone and texting
someone or posting they actually sat
there and they actually said let me
answer the question yeah let me get
uncomfortable here and what is it that I
truly want what would I have to change
about myself to be healthy to be happy
to be well successful what are my bad
habits they get busy writing down
all the the choices they want to make
all the things they want to do they
start writing down all their goals all
their experiences and every goal or
experience that I write down in their
future there's an emotion they get
inspired they get optimistic they get
grateful they get energized and those
emotions fuel more thoughts and now
they're they're they're actually
changing their biology and then they do
something really really really really
really important
they start looking at the thoughts that
they no longer want to think they write
them down I can't it's too hard I'll
start tomorrow I don't feel good until
they start looking at the choices
they're going to have to stop making and
when they they understand when they stop
making those choices it's going to be
uncomfortable that's the hardest part
about change they start thinking about
the things they have to stop doing I
gotta get off the couch I gotta stop
watching this I gotta stop over reading
whatever it is and then we've all done
this and there comes a moment where you
start noticing that like you start
saying hey I believe this is this is
actually gonna happen right and that's
when you take the foot off the gas pedal
and you start really realizing wow I was
the resource
of actually making this happen and I
changed yeah I changed in the process so
the the exciting part about it you talk
people who created wealth who talk to
people who created relationships that
are talk to people who have created
Health they'll tell you my disease
my poverty was my greatest teacher my
past was my greatest teacher they looked
back at their past and now there's no
longer an emotion associated with it the
memory without the emotional charges
wisdom now you get to go to the Future
you get to create whatever your free
willed you you could be anybody you want
to be in the process rule number eight
reconstruct your mind I think you know
one of the most important things is it's
so much easier to forget this
information than to remember even me you
know I have to say to myself okay Joe
dispenza what do you know and take a
moment and just set down my cell phone
and disconnect from everything and
really have a thought like
and keep reconstructing the model in my
mind it's so important to do that
because if we understand the what and
the why and the how it gets easier then
we assign more meaning and more belief
and more intention behind it and
and if you have to say okay
okay if I'm living by these emotions
that are familiar to me and I'm
signaling the same genes in the same way
okay now I have to be conscious of not
feeling that way and you have to make a
different choice and the hardest part
about change is stop making the same
choices you did the day before because
the moment he decided to do something
differently and making a choice it's
going to be uncomfortable you're going
to leave the known familiar world of the
familiar emotions and thoughts and
behaviors
the body is the unconscious mind is
going to want to return back to what it
knows because we trained it that way so
it's a retraining process so if the
person says okay if I can marry a clear
intention I gotta work on getting my
brain more coherent okay they got that
in the formula that'll be a good signal
out if I could slow my brain waves down
I can learn how to do that I can get
beyond my thinking I'm a little combined
I can enter the operating system of my
autonomic nervous system program that
okay if I can combine it with an
elevated emotion really practice trading
that that suffering or that pain for
something else yeah it may take me a
little bit to feel that emotion but I
think if I keep working at it I'll begin
to change my emotional state when I feel
that emotional state I'm not going to be
thinking about the past I'm going to be
thinking about the future so so the
thought and the feeling the stimulus in
response the image and the emotion is
conditioning body emotionally into the
future so the person says okay he said
or I read or someone else said the
environment signals the gene okay let me
write that down environment signals the
gene okay I gotta remember that
the end product of an experience in the
environment is the emotion okay
um if I'm feeling gratitude
and gratitude's emotional signature
means I've just received something
favorable or something wonderful just
happened to me
if I can feel the emotion of gratitude
before the event occurs
then my body would be so objective that
it's living in that future I would begin
to change my gene expression and the
stronger the emotion I feel the more I'm
going to pay attention to the picture in
my mind that I'm going to be remembering
my future my brain and body are going to
look like the event has already occurred
before it happened and if genes make
proteins and proteins are responsible
for the structure and function of my
body and the expression of proteins is
the expression of life
then I'm going to keep signaling these
I'm going to keep knocking on the door
every day and I don't care if my life is
falling apart I'm not going to fall to
that familiar emotion I'm not going to
speak the same way I'm not going to
think the same way what thoughts do I
want to fire and wire in my brain and
with intention and attention I'm going
to keep reviewing them till it becomes
an automatic thought in my head like you
can
what how am I going to be today how am I
going to be with my family I'm going to
be in traffic I'm going to be with my
co-workers how am I going to be when I'm
alone
and you start rehearsing who you're
going to be the brain in the present
moment doesn't know the difference
between the outer world or the inner
world it's the brain what it's imagining
looks real and if we're present
the brain looks like you already did it
you're priming the brain it's no longer
on record of the past now you're it's a
map to the Future you're you're in place
keep practicing that rehearsal in your
mind it's going to become automatic and
you're going to start behaving like that
person then you said
can I teach my body emotionally what
this future feels like before it happens
if you could truly open your heart and
truly feel that elevated emotion if you
kept practicing that I promise you you
would feel more of that in your day and
less of the other place and meditation
means to become familiar with and how
you think how you act and how you feel
is your personality and your personality
creates your personal reality that's the
game right so when that occurs then it's
no longer about the past and what
happened to you and the story people
tell about that they're telling a story
of their future in fact they're more in
love with their future than they are
with their past they're they're they
believe in the future more than they
believe in their past and and I think
that when we believe in ourselves we
believe in possibilities and we believe
in possibilities we have to believe in
ourselves and showing up every day
means you must believe it's true when
you stop showing up then you don't
believe it's true any longer and and
enough people that have that kind of
conviction literally step into a new
body they step into a new a new life
they step into a new future and I I hope
um that that becomes the new normal
um and and you know research says that
Collective networks of observers
determine reality that's the latest
uh so we just got to make sure enough of
us are observing a different reality
from an elevated place of Union and
connection
that instead of Separation that's that
divides communities because of survival
and stress and that's a great way to
create polarity in the world and the
union of polarity takes place in the
heart and that's where it starts it
doesn't end there it just starts there
and when I see the heart and forming the
brain I saw two students that we grabbed
one was chasing a little child around a
one and a half year old child and it was
being challenged and the other guy was
working and Staffing and running around
and we got him in the chair and we said
okay let's let's get some brain and
heart coherence and you know we had 15
20 minutes to do with these guys and you
saw them way out of balance right it's
just way out of bounds and all of a
sudden here comes that low frequency in
the heart boom like a big drum boom
boom all of a sudden you see that low
frequency the energy in the heart that's
only indigenous to the heart itself
starts rising and then all of a sudden
you see it rise and then you see the
sympathetic nervous system rise with it
so now we know they're totally relaxed
and they're totally awake and aware the
sympathetic nervous isn't working for an
arousal when you see that kind of
connection and you see someone be able
to change that
a matter of moments my eyes say they
should be able to do that with their
eyes open at any moment it should be
such a skill and that's that's when we
we maintain our energy and our power
rule number nine step into the unknown a
good way to see that is that everybody
does it like everybody does that all the
time and they would here's the problem
all of that is fine the problem is is
that they're looking
through the lens of the past that
reality they're they're seeing they're
seeing their future through the lens of
the past they can't see possibility
because they can't think greater than
how they feel or feelings have become
the means of thinking and if you believe
that your thoughts have anything to do
with your destiny then you're thinking
in the past because those emotions are
driving your thoughts and those emotions
are the familiar records of the past
right so now so let me just go one step
further so so that is
how people reaffirm themselves every
single day into a known identity and
let's just say the trauma or the
Betrayal or the loss or the shock or the
diagnosis was a profound moment that
created a strong emotion and that person
doesn't think that they have any control
of regulating and changing that emotion
because it's visceral it's somatic it's
real they feel it and that disturbance
that known they'd rather cling to that
pain they'd rather cling to that that
suffering that then to take a chance and
possibility to step outside the unknown
now the hardest part
I'm getting to time by the way the
hardest part about all of this
then is not making the same choices you
did the day before
so the moment you start to realize that
you complain that you blame that you
make excuses that you feel sorry for
yourself that you judge others that you
react emotionally to your spouse to your
ex to your co-worker to traffic the
moment you become conscious that you're
doing that and you say I'm gonna stop
well the body now the servant that is
now the mind that the servant is not a
master so now the body's clinging to the
known and you say okay I'm not going to
complain I'm not going to suffer anymore
you make a different choice and the body
says well wait a second
Jonathan you've been doing that for 30
years so you just
watch so the body starts influencing the
mind it starts sending signals back to
the brain and says you can't do this
it's too hard start tomorrow it's your
mother's fault it's your culture's fault
it's it's this it's your past
and if you accept believe and surrender
to that thought
as if it's true without really having a
critical analysis of it it slips right
by your conscious mind and it causes you
to make the same choice that leads to
the same behavior that will reproduce
the same experience and there you are on
the couch feeling the same emotion and
you say this feels right well no that
feels familiar right so that's that's
how people live in the gnome they live
in the past so the predictable future
then is everybody gets up in routine and
they're on autopilot and they run
through a series of automatic behaviors
and if you do that enough time a habit
is a redundant set of automatic
unconscious thoughts behaviors and
emotions that's acquired through
repetition do it enough times the body
will now know how to do it better than
the conscious mind it becomes implicit
right so now most people lose their free
will
to a set of programs and their body's
dragging them into a predictable future
based on what they did in the past and
that predictable future is the known as
well so if the familiar past is the
known and the predictable future is the
known there's only one place left
where the unknown exists and that's
really that sweet spot of the generous
present moment and when we truly can
become relaxed and dial down
the stress hormones that cause us to
live in survival that causes us to try
to anticipate the worst case scenario
that remembers the past if we can work
with the body and be greater than the
body
to be greater than our attention on
every element in our environment and
truly labor for the present moment that
unknown which has been conditioned to
the into the human being to be a scary
place because in survival you run from
the unknown if you can teach people to
actually relax into the present moment
and relax into that place that's the
unknown that's where possibility exists
and we all do it
and getting to that elegant moment then
time tends to alter you think only 10
minutes went by about an hour and a half
went by and where were you well as your
brain waves slow down in this process
when you're in like a thinking
analytical place like we are right now
we're in these great bearing wave
patterns called you understand beta
brainless patterns but as you slow your
body down and starts moving to Alpha
time Alpha Waves tend to cause time to
seem a little bit more elongated when
you're in Theta which is when you're
half awake and you're half asleep and
you're relaxed and awake and that level
of theta time one moment seems really
long so you have an extension of time
and turns out that you can teach people
how to do this and when you do
their autonomic nervous system begins to
regulate back into order and stress is
autonomic dysregulation and all of a
sudden the person has a sense of energy
a sense of euphoria a sense of Freedom a
sense of clarity the brains we've
measured this their brains start firing
in more ordered more coherence they it
oscillates and synchronizes different
compartments of the brain or communities
of neurons are working together and you
start feeling more whole more like
yourself in the in the understanding of
yoga as an example
if you're truly really into the ACT
you forget about all your problems you
forget about all the things you got to
do you forget about what happened
yesterday breathing is away
to really change your brain waves as
we've studied this thousands of times
you slow your breathing down you slung
your brain waves down you slow your
brain waves down and you stop analyzing
and thinking when do you over analyze
and overthink when you're in high high
high beta and when's that when you're
threatened when you feel danger when
when the stress hormones are running and
we've studied the brain when this
happens and when you're analyzing your
life within that disturbing emotion I
can guarantee you you're going to make
your brain worse in fact your thought of
the problem is actually producing the
very chemistry to arouse you further out
of balance so teaching people
how to find that generous present moment
and actually relax in the unknown and
dissociate from their body dissociate
from their environment and dissociate
from time the predictable future and the
familiar past causes them for some
reason to get a reboot in in their
nervous system and they think oh God it
must have been 10 minutes and oh my God
it was it was an hour and a half that
that to me
is taking all of your attention or
disinvesting all of your attention out
of this three-dimensional reality and
that's when the door to Creation or the
mystical moment really begins to happen
for people and Rule Number 10 the last
one before some very special bonus Clips
is create the life you want if you think
about
the illusion of three-dimensional
reality and and this hologram that were
fooled into our senses into this concept
of Separation there's me here and
there's you there and there's distance
in space and there's objects and there's
things in this three-dimensional reality
causes us to go from one point of
awareness I'm here to another point of
awareness uh say the front door and we
have to move through space and we move
through space it takes time right so
anything that we want in our lives takes
time and energy got to go to work
and you gotta you know you gotta do all
the things and then you got to save
money and then you go buy the thing and
that's the rules of three-dimensional
reality the plane of demonstration means
you got to do something right so then
there's me here and then my dreams are
way way out there and I estimate how
long it's going to take for me to arrive
at those streams because we're playing
by the rules of three-dimensional
reality and we play by those rules
um
for the most part I'm gonna wait for the
experience to occur in order to have the
experience producing emotion and the
emotion is the chemical feedback as a
result of the event now there's nothing
wrong with this that's the game in in
three-dimensional world
if you're going to shorten the distance
between cause and effect uh between the
thought of something and the experience
of something you got to go to a
different set of rules and you have to
create from the quantum field now the
quantum field is an invisible field of
energy that exists Beyond this space and
time now this takes a little bit of
imagination because
if we don't have any space between us
then we're connected there's no
separation uh and and there's no time so
now when you go to the realm of a
Quantum the rules change because in the
quantum things are connected energy
connects things together
so then if you were able to create from
the field instead of from matter and
it's not matter that's emitting a field
it's the field that's actually creating
matter if we could change information in
the field we could change the Hologram
in three-dimensional reality and it
turns out you only need two things to do
that
in a super coherent brain super
organized coherent brain and coherence
is a rhythm on order so when the brain
is coherent it has a directive it's an
electrical charge it's the signal we
send out into the field we're
broadcasting information with our
thoughts now most people who have been
conditioned and hypnotized into the
rules of three-dimensional reality
they're waiting for the experience to
happen to feel the emotion of the
experience to take away their lack or
separation like whatever it's abundance
it's love it's healing whatever it is
but in the quantum model
you have to combine that clear intention
with an elevated emotion and that takes
heart coherence so we've done extensive
studies in training our community to
begin to feel the emotion of the event
before it happens and people say well I
don't know how it would feel because I
haven't experienced it well the answer
is really simple
if you felt gratitude or you felt
appreciation or a love for life or a joy
for existence
and you combine that clear intention
with an elevated emotion the heart
produces a magnetic field and that
magnetic field expands out and it
transcends the rules of space and time
when you feel whole when you feel this
elevated emotion you feel connected you
feel bonded and so when you feel the
emotion of your future
you're connecting to the energy of the
future and your body is so objective it
does not know the difference between the
real life experience that's creating
that emotion and the emotion that you're
creating by thought alone the body's
actually believing it's living in that
future reality in the present moment so
if the thought sends the signal out and
the feeling draws the event back and
your brain and hard coherence you got a
really powerful Wi-Fi signal
and when you begin to do this properly
you no longer have to go anywhere to get
anything in other words you're not
living by the rules of of cause and
effect you're living by the rules of
causing an effect you're producing an
outcome now here's the cool part if
there's a vibrational match between your
energy and you've really refined that
signal
and you can synchronize your energy you
start having synchronicities in your
life and you start getting Universal
science coming to you you have
opportunities you have synchronicities
serendipities coincidences and you're
not going anywhere to get it they're
coming to you now think about this if
you're connected to an invisible field
of energy that's the source of
everything physical and material if you
were Connected To Source why would you
go anywhere you wouldn't do that you
would say come to me right so so by
doing this properly
and causing an effect when you see
feedback in your life as the result of
what you're doing
you're going to pay attention to what
you did and you're going to do it again
now the cool part is is that once you
feel the excitement the inspiration The
Joy The Love For Life
that's actually reinforcing the feeling
that you've created with and if you
create again you refine the signal a bit
more you get more synchronicities no
more opportunities and the cool part
about our community
is that they're not saying oh God I have
to go create my life they're not saying
that they actually don't want to stop
doing it because they don't want those
they don't want the magic to end they
don't want those cool Quantum events
that are occurring in their life to stop
so it's not like I have to they're just
they're changing their energy and when
you change your energy you change your
life and I've been at this long enough
to tell you that nobody changes until
they change their energy and and and so
when you experiment with this as a as a
process and you learn a particular
formula and we've been we've been
refining this and studying it so much in
the last couple years
that the amount of coherence that we see
in some of our student Community is so
incredibly organized and not only
organized but the amount of energy in
the brain the amount of energy in the
heart is higher amplitude so no bigger
signal bigger Wi-Fi signal more
connection and so then you if you can
shorten the distance
between cause and effect
between the thought of what you want and
the experience of what you want
then you would start to master your life
and then you would start to see wow I
could actually if I if I could do this
what could I do next and and I'm happy
to say that you know people are doing it
pretty well
I have sat in meditations and out of
nowhere I had the most icky
so familiar but so foreign feeling moved
through me that it was I don't know I
never saw it coming I didn't know what
it was
and all I did was instead of run and
turn on my cell phone or lay down or
quit I was curious if there was
something on the other side of it
so if I stay present with it and felt it
it was an energy and that energy is a
frequency and that frequency carries
information or the emotion as a memory
however you want to say it
and so you have to pass through the
valley of the shadow of Darkness many
times to find light and I have sat with
my body
curious to wonder if there's anything on
the other side of this emotion and if I
stayed present with it and felt it it
would turn into something else in time
and so then
think about it you know we have
different Sensations that our body
experiences you may feel like a
tightening in your throat in your
respiratory rate going up and kind of
flush
in your heart
and you may be feeling
anxious but all of those Sensations that
the body is recording your
interpretation of it is anxiety or being
anxious so the sensations then the human
Sensations as information we call it an
emotions the moment we name it it's
anxiety but those Sensations that come
up for the body is information so people
then sitting in the presence of that
information
and allowing you to experience it fully
will cause you to move through it now
for me
I'm all about this
if it's familiar if it's a familiar
feeling more than likely I'm back in
some unconscious program
because the emotion is driving certain
behaviors certain habits certain
thoughts now that doesn't mean that
people can't go through grieving
processes but I do believe that that
process for some people becomes a way
for them to get attention
and to get things in their life that
they need and they use it in a way that
becomes part of their identity and they
do that unconsciously
and so for me I would say then what
greater piece of knowledge could I learn
about grief or about myself that I would
want to apply to evolve my experience of
it and see if there's something on the
other side of it so
we look for those answers then and we
build a model
and for example people grieve a lot for
for people that die and I totally get it
but if you had a greater understanding
of death
you may not have such a grief for that
long because you would say my goodness
if I truly love this person if you pass
this plane and you saw someone you loved
walking around suffering what would you
say to them after a period of time
hey if you love me live your life come
on I'm going on go enjoy so I always
look what is my limited belief about
about something and could I learn to to
expand my awareness of what's possible
so if you feel the grief stay present
with it
and see by staying present with it if
there's something on the other side sit
with it long enough I I have I've had so
many dark nights I've sat with it until
it turned into something else I just I
just was curious I didn't want anything
out there to do it
I wanted to do it and when it matters
the most is when it's the hardest that's
what I know if you think about gratitude
when when you receive something
favorable or you just receive something
favorable if something's happening to
you or something just happened to you
that you are excited about
um you feel grateful so the emotional
signature of gratitude means that it's
already happened or something wonderful
is happening to you now the body is so
objective
that it does not know the difference
between a real life experience that's
creating that emotion and that emotion
that you're fabricating by thought alone
so the body's believing it's living in
an environmental condition that's
favorable to you
and we only accept believe and surrender
to thoughts that are equal to our
emotional state so in the state of
gratitude your body is more prone to be
programmed through its autonomic nervous
system into a different Destiny and the
research that we've done uh in our in
our on our research team shows that just
four days of feeling gratitude
can strengthen your immune system by 50
percent by releasing a an immunoglobulin
called immunoglobulin a which is their
body's primary defense against bacteria
and viruses is better than any flu shot
and it's the body's natural capacity so
so when we trade
anger and frustration and fear and
anxiety and pain and suffering and guilt
for an elevated emotion the autonomic
nervous system starts to regulate back
into homeostasis imbalance and of course
stress is when the autonomic nervous
system is knocked out of homeostasis
imbalance it's dysregulation so we teach
people how to give thanks for the things
that they create in their life actually
before it happens and when we do that
properly
we start to see measurable changes in
the person's body and measurable changes
in their energy and ultimately
measurable changes in their life so the
concept of presence is such an important
concept because I think that paying
attention is being present and it's a
skill just like anything else the more
you practice it the better you get at it
and I think we know when people are
present with us in our lives is because
they're paying attention to us and we
know when they're not present with us
because they're not paying attention
well where you place your attention is
where you place your energy bottom line
so if you're thinking about what's going
to happen in the next moment or what's
going to happen in a day or you're
reviewing what's something that happened
three days ago you're placing your
attention in some future scenario or
some past memory and we siphon energy
out of the present moment and we don't
have available energy then to really
begin to create an outcome in our lives
but if we're truly present and we're
relaxed and poised in the present moment
if where you place your attention is
where you place your energy then you
have a lot of energy in the present
moment to execute a lot of energy in the
present moment to make decisions the
more you do this the more you experience
those moments of flow the
synchronicities the serendipities the
opportunities the coincidences because
there's a lot of power in the present
moment so one of the key elements in the
creative process is teaching people how
to relax into the present moment so if a
person is thinking about their problems
and those problems are memories that are
etched in their brain that are connected
to certain people and objects and things
at certain times and places the moment
they think about their problems say
first thing in the morning when they
wake up
if you believe your thoughts have
something to do with your destiny and
your brain is a record of the past the
moment you remember your problems you're
thinking in the past and because every
problem has an emotion Associated
because you experience it the moment you
feel unhappy now your body's in the past
so thoughts are the language of the
brain and feelings of the language of
the body and and how we think and how we
feel creates our state of being so most
people
unconsciously start their day
with their entire state of being
biologically in the past and again the
body's so objective it doesn't know the
difference between the real life
experience uh uh and the emotion that
you're creating by thought alone so that
past that familiar past is called the
known and if you wake up in the morning
and you start thinking about
the predictable future and the people
you have to see and the places you have
to go and the things you have to do in
your routine predictable life
the same exact thing happens you're
you're imagining that future scenario
that's already known to you and you're
anticipating the feeling of that outcome
so that becomes the predictable future
becomes the known as well so if the
familiar past is the known and the
predictable future is the known there's
only one place where the unknown exists
and that's the sweet spot of the
generous present moment in teaching
people how to create from the present
moment is what begins to produce the
magic and the changes that take place in
their lives what's emerging in the world
now because of information
information is teaching people that
there are other possibilities that they
were unconscious to and you don't need
an authority any longer you don't need a
priest you don't need a governor you
don't need a teacher you don't need a
doctor to gain information any longer
information is available but the
question is
what will you do with it so if you give
people sound scientific information and
science is the language of mysticism and
you combine quantum physics with
neuroscience and neuroendocrinology and
psychon or immunology and epigenetics
and electromagnetism and make it simple
and don't talk about tradition or
religion or culture that's going to
divide it on the audience but bring the
model of Science in
a person can reason and understand what
they're doing with that information
and why they're doing it then the side
effect of how they're doing it is going
to get easier and now the application
becomes essential so what we're seeing
is this the emergent Consciousness where
people are taking their power back
and not relying on anyone or anything
for their own personal change or
transformation and I think that when you
get enough people doing it emergence in
biology is a group of birds all moving
in the same direction of school of fish
all moving the appearance is a larger
organism they're behaving in the exact
same way there's no leader when you
study that in biology everybody's
leading so how are we going to change
the world it's not one person not one
Consciousness it's a collective
Consciousness and the research says that
Collective networks of observers
determine reality get enough people
believing in possibility sooner or later
someone's going to run into that
experience and you need one once you
know it's possible then other people
will start doing it as well just like
the four minute mile so
so in the world right now I think we're
seeing it breaking down
of so many conventions where whether
it's religion or medicine or the
environment there's journalism
everything's falling apart right now
because it can't sustain itself because
no organisms in nature live in this kind
of abusive competition we organisms
survive in cooperation and connection
and communion
keep people in fear
keep them angry keep them in pain keep
them all all those survival emotions
you'll never have Community you bring
people into an elevated emotional state
something innate in the human species
says we're empathic to one another and
we celebrate one another we want to get
along with one another we want to
cooperate we want to resolve issues
together that's that's who we are when
we're not living in stress and survival
if your personality is made up of how
you think how you act and how you feel
and it is yes or no
and you stop thinking the same way and
nerve cells that no longer fire together
no longer wire together every place
where one neuron connects with another
neurons called the memory
so as you begin to unfire and unwire you
prune the very circuits in your brain
that are connected to the old self and
the memory
of the old self begins to mutate begins
to change so then you would say where
is that memory stored and it's stored in
the soul now
as wisdom because you're no longer that
person yes or no
and if you could no longer behave the
same way in nerve cells that no longer
fire together no longer wire together
and pruning is part of biology you don't
use it you lose it
then your memory of the old self would
begin to change and that is a biological
death in the beginning that is
uncomfortable for a lot of people
if you're no longer feeling the same
emotions that keep you connected to the
past and you keep inhibiting that
process the body will be craving the
chemicals in the beginning because it's
been conditioned that way it's been it's
been addicted it's the mind and it's
anticipating events and the emotions
from those events and you're putting the
brakes on
and that's uncomfortable and you got to
stay conscious and it takes an enormous
amount of energy and you're no longer
signaling the same genes and producing
the same hormones and your body is no
longer being influenced by your mind in
the same way
and sometimes the mind is the biggest
enemy to the body
and you're inhibiting that process
and the body which has become the Mind
wants its way
and it's uncomfortable to change and you
got to be able to be greater than that
to truly change and everybody that's
changed has come up against that feeling
and they almost make the same choice and
they don't and they're so glad that they
didn't
and it takes an enormous amount of
energy and awareness to do that so as
the old self
deconstructs because you have the free
will to decide who you want to be on a
moment-to-moment basis and if your life
isn't changing and you want to change
your life you got to change and now you
are playing the game and you are now
saying this personality
this person that I've become I'm in the
habit of being it and I want to become
somebody else
and the more you learn about love the
more you learn about life the more you
learn about possibility and potential
the more you become aware of it there
are more possibilities and knowledge is
the thing that gives us that
and so the old self
is a memory like another lifetime like
you can remember it but you're no longer
interested in it any longer because it
no longer defines you
how many people understand what I'm
talking about so then the biological
death of the old self is crossing a
river of change and you got to stay with
it long enough to become somebody else
and you think it's about wealth it's you
think it's about health it's about who
you become
the people who become somebody else they
they see dramatic changes in their
health and in their lives
and and they can't find the words to be
able to explain it
but it's practical though if you truly
want to change your life you have to
change yourself you would have to be
conscious of your thoughts and aware of
your actions and and familiar with those
emotions and you would never fall from
grace and if you did you would stop and
self-correct if you truly were
interested in evolution and if you said
to me it's I lost it because of that
person
I'd say that you're back to the
unconscious program of allowing your
environment to control how you feel and
think you got two choices stay there
for another six hours or pause and
change your energy change your energy
and get back to the emotions of your
future and the feelings of your future
it's a much better place to be
reason this with me
you could have a great meditation and
condition your body just like you did
into the future
you come back to your senses and you
return back to the same old self romance
in the past again
you're going to weigh that one 50 minute
one hour meditation against the rest of
the day back to you
you got to start practicing we have to
start doing it with our eyes open and
the font of who we want to become should
produce the feeling of it
instantaneously in other words the
thought of your future should produce
the feeling that it already happened
instead of the feeling of lack because
it hasn't happened
how many people understand that and the
people who do this well they condition
their body into the future and they say
I don't know how it happened it's like
my body was led right to the event and
your body is going to follow your mind
to an unknown just like it follows your
mind to the toilet every morning but
instead of it being known it's going to
be the unknown
that's where your attention and your
energy has been
I'm telling you it doesn't matter what
you believe in doesn't matter the color
your skin what you eat I don't care it
doesn't matter I've seen it in all ways
so then the thought of our future if
we're doing this properly should produce
the feeling that it already happened
if the thought of your future produces
the lack that it hasn't happened you're
still in your past and nothing is going
to change
and it would make sense then that you
would want to get that heart open on a
regular basis so that you can feel the
emotions of your future before it
happens I'm telling you there's a lot of
biology that changes in you
can you do it enough times you become
that person
the thought of it then produces the
feeling that it's already happened
that's how you know you're getting close
independent of what's going on in your
life
that's when you're mastering yourself
and mastering your life when we become
the living example of Truth when we
actually embody this
that there are no limits to what we can
do and I'm hopeful with human beings
that that we have this capacity and and
of course when we believe in ourselves
we believe in possibility and when we
leave in possibilities we believe in
ourselves and I think that is the
ultimate belief feelings and emotions
are the end product of past experiences
and you can remember experiences better
because you can remember how they feel
and when you're in the midst of an
experience
all of your senses plug you into the
environment
and as you're Gathering all of this
vital data from your external world
all that information rushes back to your
brain and it causes jungles of neurons
to organize themselves into Networks
the moment those neurons string into
place the brain makes a chemical and
that chemical is called a feeling or an
emotion
and once you feel that emotion you
create a long-term memory
now reason this with me
if feelings and emotions are the end
product of past experiences
and you are feeling the same way every
single day
doesn't that mean nothing new is
happening in your life
and of those feelings and emotions Drive
certain thoughts
and you can't think greater than how you
feel
because you had events in your life that
have branded you emotionally
and you feel sadness or guilt or shame
or unworthiness or insecurity all of
those emotions are created from past
experiences
and when you feel those emotions
and those emotions Drive certain
thoughts
and then those thoughts make certain
chemicals for you to feel the same
emotion
and then those emotions Drive certain
thoughts
the repetition of that cycle then
conditions the body
to memorize that emotional state better
than the mind
and now your body literally is in the
past
because if you can't think greater than
how you feel then you are thinking in
the past
and so most people then spend the
majority of their life talking about why
they never arrive at their vision of the
future
because of some past experience
and so if feelings and emotions are the
end product of past experiences you
remember your first kiss you remember
your wedding you remember the birth of
your children you remember catching a
fish off the coast of manzanillo with
your three best friends
because you caught the fish and it was a
new experience and you felt great
and then you went to the Casita and you
cooked the mahi mahi and you drank
sauvignon blanc and the wind was blowing
off the Sea and the sun was setting and
you made a long-term memory
[Music]
but you also have memories that are
connected to trauma and crisis
to disappointments
and those are the memories that people
remember more than anything else
and so if you haven't overcome some
emotion
that keeps you anchored to the Past
then you tell a story about the past
and people say I am this way because of
this experience that happened to me 15
years ago
I am this way because of some event that
happened 30 years ago
and from a biological perspective it
means I haven't been able to change in
the last 15 or 30 years
and Scientific American
a prestigious magazine
says that 50 percent of what you talk
about in your past isn't even the truth
you make it up
because you don't have the same brain
that you did 15 years ago or 30 years
ago
so then your brain and body are
typically in the past
because thoughts are the language of the
brain and feelings are the language of
the body
and how you think and how you feel
creates your state of being
so if you think insecure thoughts in a
matter of seconds you are going to feel
insecure
the moment you feel insecure
your brain is monitoring how you're
feeling and you think more insecure
thoughts which then makes you feel more
insecure
and the repetition of that cycle
conditions the body to become the mind
of insecurity and then the person says I
am insecure
and whenever you say I am anything you
are commanding your mind and body into a
destiny
so then how do people change
they wait for crisis trauma disease
diagnosis loss something has to go wrong
in their life
where they feel so uncomfortable that
they finally make up their mind to
change
and why is that
because after the trauma or the crisis
they don't feel like of themselves
and the moment they don't feel like
themselves they could actually observe
themselves
because they are looking at themselves
Through The Eyes of someone else
but my message is why wait
you can learn and change in a state of
pain and suffering
or you can learn and change in a state
of joy and inspiration memory is
creative that in fact fifty percent of
that story you embellish people make up
that story let me tell you why they make
up that story
because they excuse themselves for the
fact that they haven't been able to
change
since that event they'll have to make it
sound worse than it really was to make
it harder to grow and change so that
they can reaffirm their limited sense of
their inability to change so then that
story becomes more and more of a story
it's less of the truth because you got
to work yourself up into a state there
were lions and tigers and they were
right you know they were helicopters
snowstorms didn't matter everybody was
firing bullets the worst thing you could
possibly imagine and then you've got to
feel that emotion right and then you're
looking oh yeah it must have been really
bad now that's that's your identity now
that's your identity if you are not
defined by some vision
that is bigger than you
and you are not passionate about that
Vision then you're left with the old
Hardware of the past in your brain and
you will be predictable in your life
so would you agree then
new thoughts
new information should lead to new
choices
new choices should lead to new behaviors
and new behaviors should create new
experiences
and new experiences should produce new
emotions and those new emotions should
drive new thoughts and that's called
evolution
so if your brain is a record of the past
and you don't have a vision of the
future
then you are living in the past
and you will never arrive at that new
future if you have been inexperienced uh
if you had experience of trauma say for
example and it's created the feeling of
fear and your fears that it could happen
again
and you're you don't know this but every
time you think about that future that
possible worst case scenario scenario
and you feel the emotion you're
conditioning your body to become the
Mind subconsciously of anxiety
so now all you need now is some cue in
your outer environment that says it's
unsafe that if there's damage there that
you're you're a victim something's
bigger than you that could have an
effect on you well now that feeling of
fear is going to cause you to think
thoughts equal to it so the person then
no longer needs the environment to feel
that fear they just have to have the
thought about that condition now and now
they're literally knocking their brain
and body out of balance by thought alone
and the body's constantly living in
emergency mode and it takes a lot of
energy
a lot of resources to live in emergency
mode all the time guess what system
becomes compromised by the immune system
your immune system why because you have
two Protection Systems you gotta you got
a system that protects you from dangers
in your outer world that's that's the
gas pedal that's the sympathetic nervous
system that's a fight or flight nervous
system danger threat out there use all
the energy because you gotta you gotta
survive and when you survive you got to
take care of your body so right so so
now
that system can work really well short
term
it doesn't work really well if you keep
it on all the time because if you're
mobilizing all that energy for some
threat in your outer world there's no
energy in your inner world for growth
and repair there's no energy for
long-term building projects and energy
leaves the brain and it leaves the heart
and it moves into these lower centers
because now you're tapping the body's
resources because there is an emergency
but whether the emergency is real or
imagined whether your anger is valid or
Justified or not
that the you're tapping the body's very
energy to heal by doing this and the
immune system says well we're part of
really the other nervous system we're
the break we're the clutch we need the
we need to get into relaxation we need
to get back into balance again and and
when we do then we'll metabolize then
we'll we'll assimilate we'll reproduce
we'll we'll excrete properly so
so now you got a this kind of battle
between the gas pedal and the brake and
the immune system says Hey listen if
there's foreign agents if there's
viruses bacteria molds funguses listen
we don't have a whole lot of energy here
to deal with them because we're fighting
this war out there there's no Homeland
Security so they shut down certain
receptors in the immune system they shut
down function of those lymphocytes those
white blood cells that are your inner
Army of protection and it takes a lot of
energy to fight a virus and a bacteria
but if there's no energy Hey listen it
takes energy to raise the body's
temperature what do you think that comes
from that's part of that branch called
the autonomic nervous system and the
sympathetic the gas pedal is part of it
and the parasympathetic is the clutch is
part of that autonomic nervous system
and it's a check and balance but so you
stay in emergency for an extended period
of time
and now you're exposed to some antigen
or some external substance some foreign
agent why is our memory
for
pain stronger than our memory of a
success or a joy I really think that
when the survival Gene is activated
preservation is the key so we can have
10 things
that happen really great in our lives
you have a family member or somebody you
know that does this they have 10 really
great things happen in their one thing
bad and they focus on that bad thing why
because the survival genes activated
they want to make sure it doesn't happen
again so so you put your attention on it
because you don't want it to happen
again so what people do when they're
aroused is they start thinking it's
going to happen so they actually select
the worst case scenario in their mind
and then emotionally Embrace that future
before it happens and they're
conditioning their body it's become the
mind of anxiety and fear so in
preservation and in survival if you
prepare for the worst
anything less that happens you have a
better chance of surviving so that's the
mechanism that takes place so
survival means you better take care of
your body yeah you better be aware of
your environment and make sure there's
no threats and so you got to keep your
eye out there
and you better be thinking about the
future based on what you learned in the
past now there's nothing wrong with that
when the analytical facilities are in
Balance but when there's an arousal
arousals there's three things that
create arousal fear
hostility and anger or aggression and
pain
and that arousal drives the brain
into these high states of what we call
High beta and most people need something
or someone or some circumstance or some
drug or some pill or some computer game
to change that internal State and the
moment they notice a change in their
Eternal safe and they pay attention to
what's causing it they start developing
a dependency on it right so
turns out that when we teach people how
to self-regulate and change their brain
waves we could actually see then that
the incoherence that disorderliness
that's taking place in the brain you
know when you're over aroused you're
overly analytical and you're shifting
your attention from one problem to one
person to one thing to one place to
another problem to another circumstance
to your phone to your car and each one
of those elements has a neurological
Network in the brain so the arousal
causes these different circuits to fire
out of order and the brain is incoherent
so take two waves that are out of phase
and mix them when they interfere they
flatten out there's no energy so energy
leaves the brain right
so then
when you're in arousal you narrow your
focus on the cause if there is something
rattling in the bushes and it's dark you
freeze and you narrow your focus on it
and there's a rush of adrenaline and
your pupils dilate and your heart starts
to race and you're ready to run fight or
hide I mean that's a survival moment but
what if it's your co-worker sitting
right next to you or six feet away and
and you're judging them you're the same
arousals taking place so what's once
very adaptive becomes very maladaptive
this is where it gets challenging so
when we teach people how to open their
focus we've done thousands and thousands
of brain scans and they get beyond their
analytical processes and they open their
awareness and go from a conversion Focus
to a divert and focus and they learn how
to relax and regulate their brain waves
start to slow down into Alpha and then
if they do it properly and they're
connecting
those different compartments of the
brain that were once firing out of order
start to unify different communities
form bigger communities the brain starts
to synchronize and then all of a sudden
you start seeing different compartments
of the brain all in resonance so now
when they're all in resonance and they
start interfering when those waves come
together there's more energy in the
brain so when a person dials down the
mechanism this neocortex that plugs us
into three-dimensional reality that
keeps us aware of our body that's the
autobiographical self where everything's
stitched in memory in there when we
start deactivating the mechanism here
and we get beyond the memory bank of the
known self and brain waves move into
Theta we we've studied this so much
when a person can let their body
be in a light state of sleep and feel so
safe
that you can finally let go and
surrender the body is sleeping but the
mind is awake and now the door between
the conscious mind and the subconscious
mind is wide open and if they can
regulate and stay there
something amazing happens
there is a release of energy
from the body and their brain goes into
a very very super coherent state of
gamma gamma is super Consciousness now
I'm not talking about
a little camera I'm not talking about a
lot of gamma I'm not talking about a
really loud camera I'm talking about a
supernatural amount of gamma
so there's so much order
and so much energy in the brain like if
we were in an audience and we were all
clapping like this
that could be Alpha right Theta would be
and if everybody could do this it's
slower we could do it the more we can
get our timing down the more we can get
coherent but if we were doing
this would be really hard for all of us
to do that at the same time so it takes
a lot of order a lot of awareness a lot
of energy to be able to create that kind
of order so
that's how fast the brain is in that
arousal that's taking place is ecstasy
that arousal is bliss it is the most
familiar unfamiliar feeling that people
ever have and that memory then that the
person has that is so profoundly
different than the feeling of success
the feeling of wealth the feeling of uh
orgasm or love or whatever this is a new
one and it's a thrill
and the person notices a dramatic change
in their inner State and with that
experience comes a very lucid picture a
very profound Insight a download of
information
that's the moment then the body many
times rewrites the biological program
energy
is informing matter and the autonomic
nervous system is regulating it's in
high order and remember diseases
autonomic dysregulation now it's getting
into a very very high frequency of order
and it's sending very coherent
information to the cells and tissues
sending energy to the cells and tissues
and cells begin to emit more coherent
light and information and then there's
the disease
and there it's not Bond University a
university in Australia on the Gold
Coast senior researcher took a large
majority of my brain scans
and they hadn't she had them analyzed by
her graduate students and they
statistically looked at everything
one of the most startling things for the
research team was our community's
ability
to go to to get to that point where
they're nobody no one no thing nowhere
no time I'm talking four seconds I'm
talking five seconds I'm talking nine
seconds just like just give me a second
I know how to do this they they've
practiced it enough times that the
creative moment is when you get Beyond
yourself when you dissociate from
everything known in your Material World
Turns out when you do that and you start
changing your brain waves
your brain waves slow down into Alpha
and Theta you're suppressing the memory
bank of the known self that keeps you
plugged into three-dimensional reality
when you quiet down this mechanism
now all of a sudden you start connecting
to that field and when you can stay
conscious in those subconscious Realms
when you can literally regulate and
change brain waves now you're in the
operating system where you can make
those significant changes I believe in
Free Will I would never tell anybody
what to believe like politically or
socially or whatever I I want to provide
them the tools and give them the free
will to create life however they want
and believe whatever they want that's
totally cool with me
so those people then
that want to be healed
and they live in fear
that fear has to be addressed I mean and
it's not easy because it's re it's
hardwired deep in the limbic brain it's
just a safety net it's a mechanism so
then imagine being in the unknown
that the Instinct and the unknown is
it's a Scary Place wow imagine not
having a body and we practice lingering
without a body in in in an infinite
space and not without a name without a
face without a culture without a job
without a social security number without
a disease without a diet just as an
awareness you you practice that
you're going to be comfortable in the
unknown you're going to relax more into
it that's going against
thousands of years of programming and
the people who actually overcome their
fear
and they traded for gratitude their
immune system gets stronger their genes
have regulate I mean there's just a host
of uh everything their brain changes
their heart rate variability they feel
differently and it's it's being measured
and some of these people were measuring
this now in our in our events with with
reputable scientists in in universities
they're they're
shocked at what they're witnessing on a
cellular level on a brain level on a
heart level
they cannot believe
the capacity of the body I it just was I
just got an email today of assigned one
of our scientists said I ran this
three times
the virus that we exposed the cell to in
advance meditators does not enter the
cell it's outside the cell it won't a
virus and novice meditators some of it's
in the cell some of it's outside
controls all the viruses in the cell
there's an immunity so when the person's
less reactionary to their environment
there's less of response that weakens
them they're less of a victim to their
environment then they're less of a
victim to their environment
large-scale small scale the body has a
greater immunity to whatever it is I
think we've been hypnotized and
conditioned into becoming materialists I
think
that we Define reality with our senses
and I think that is one of the biggest
Illusions so the fundamental question is
can you believe in a future
that you can't see or experience with
your senses yet but you've thought about
enough times in your mind that your
brain has literally changed to look like
the event has already occurred now the
latest research in plasticity says
that's absolutely possible and can you
select a new possibility in the quantum
field and begin to emotionally Embrace
that future every single day to such a
degree that your body as the unconscious
mind the objective mind does not know
the difference between the experience in
your life that's creating the emotion
and the emotion that you're fabricating
by thought alone to the degree that you
begin to Signal new genes in new ways to
change your body to look like the
experience has already happened now yes
the latest research in epigenetics says
it's absolutely possible now think about
this every day
installing the circuitry every day
conditioning the body into the emotion
of the future that your body begins to
change to look like it's already
happened now this is where it gets fun
because now you no longer have to go
anywhere to get it now it begins to come
to you you become the vortex or the
magnet to your destiny so then people
who come out of their meditation and
they say well I just focused on my
wealth why isn't it there well you're
not that good if you're asking why isn't
it there you're back to the old person
again
stay in that state for an extended
period of time
as
an experiment as the scientist in your
life to keep your energy connected to
the to the dream of your future
and then see what kind of effects begin
to take place without moving into
impatience without moving into
frustration without starting to analyze
why it hasn't happened or when that is
the Trap of defining reality with your
senses so you have the thought of your
future and you don't see it then you
experience separation but people who are
practicing this work they have the
thought of their future and they feel
the emotion of their future they're
still connected to it right so that
takes practice and it's just learning
like hitting a golf ball hitting a
tennis ball dancing the salsa you know
crocheting whatever it is you gotta you
gotta start out staying real conscious
and learning then you get good at it and
gets to be instrumental gets to be fun
and that's that's what I want for
everybody that the Act of Creation
should be a blissful life ecstatic loose
free process and um and so
I love the idea of people taking time
out of their lives
to prove to themselves that if they're
defined by the vision of the future then
they're not living by the memories of
the past and that's where the unknown
exists so many people the unknown is a
scary place so they don't see that
future because they're used to seeing
that future with evidence with their
senses and the you have to be able to
get beyond that and stay in the unknown
stay in that discomfort and then in that
moment to be begin to self-regulate like
oh I'm starting to feel a little anxiety
ooh I'm starting to feel a little
frustration that's the defining moment
where your body's going back to the past
because emotions are a record of the
past or you go into routine again so you
catch yourself
it's a victory and if you keep catching
yourself those victories add up and it's
not so much about your wealth or your
health or your freedom or your new
relationship
it's actually about who you become if we
teach a person then how to trade that
frustration or that hatred for an
elevated emotion and they'll say yeah
but you know it was my ex's fault or I
got betrayed by my partner in business
yeah yeah we know that okay so let's
take your partner in business or take
your ex let's duct tape them put them in
a cannon and shoot them to the moon now
what are you gonna do sooner or later
you got to reckon with yourself and
change right so then teach a person then
how to trade that emotion for an
elevated emotion now trade the emotion
for an elevated emotion right so you're
going to give that up and you're going
to practice feeling gratitude for as an
example yes the person says well I can't
feel gratitude and I say absolutely you
can because you don't practice feeling
it you practice spending most of your
time feeling hatred and frustration so
now it's going to take a little time to
cause that heart of you to bloom or your
heart of yours to bloom once they're
able to feel even the smallest measure
of gratitude where they start feeling
appreciation thankfulness
gratitude its emotional signature when
you when you get something when you're
receiving something
when something has happened to you
uh or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature
of gratitude means the event has already
happened where it's happening to you so
the moment you open your heart and you
feel gratitude well that emotion then is
telling the body that the experience has
already occurred and the thought then
can make it into the body because it's
consistent with the thought so now
you're beginning to program the
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific Destiny you got to maintain
that modified State of Mind and Body
your entire day independent of the
conditions in your outer environment
independent of your body's Cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can get
ready because something weird or unusual
some synchronicity some coincidence some
opportunity is going to land in your lap
and you didn't have to go and get it yes
it came to you now you're the vortex of
creation so if you say to me well I was
feeling gratitude but then there was
traffic or my co-worker sent me a nasty
email that I would say oh my God God you
mean you're allowing your environment
your outer environment to control how
you feel and think you're back to the
unconscious program that you're the
victim to your life you got it but when
you start producing those outcomes in
your life you're going to pay attention
to what you did inside of you and you're
going to believe more that you're the
creator of your life unless of the
victim of your life I think this is a
time in history where it's not enough to
know this is a time in history to know
how and if you rewind the tape 10 years
ago you know information was the thing
that stimulated thought stimulated new
ideas and and as we learn new things we
make new Connections in our brains so as
we begin to add new Stitches into that
three-dimensional tapestry in our mind
we're beginning to cause our mind to
function in new ways but the key then is
to apply it to personalize it to do
something with it and in 10 years ago
when I went got in front of an audience
and talked about the application it
nobody wanted to step outside that
philosophical theoretical intellectual
realm right because doing something
means you're gonna have to change
something about yourself painful yeah
you're going to get uncomfortable right
and
um I think we're in an age of
information
and in an age of information ignorance
is a choice and because of Technology we
have access to so much content and
information creates awareness and
awareness is consciousness and you can't
have Consciousness without energy there
they work together so there's an
energetic change I think that's taking
place in the world right now where
people are so informed
that old models old paradigms are
beginning to break down whether it's a
medical model or the religious model the
educational model journalism uh the
economy you know politics it's all
beginning to come to the surface because
something else has to come out and and I
think that one of the things that people
are realizing is that you don't have to
be a Buddhist monk to do this or a nun
with 40 Years of devotion you just got
to understand the formula and just like
any skill or anything you learn
you got to go from thinking to doing to
being you got to take knowledge you
create the experience and if you keep
doing it over and over again you start
getting a skill or you start getting
wise about how to do it and you you know
that you know how to do it overcoming
the old self
allows us to become somebody else and
there is that period of transition yeah
I call it the void where there's just
not a lot happening
and you just got to be able yeah to keep
going and continuously get to the end of
your belief where most people stop I
just had a fabulous conversation with
someone this weekend
broke through to the other side and now
there's so much magic happening around
this person but she's worthy now to
receive it and that's that that is the
key because the universe only gives us
what we think we're worthy of receiving
so we gotta come initiated into this and
understand it thousands of years of
programming that says that we have to
change things matter to matter you know
in three-dimensional reality and it will
take time but
to begin to connect to that resource
called the quantum field and create from
the field instead of from matter
there's a lot of unlearning that has to
go on
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from John Assaraf
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there a lot of athletes
have this term around the a game and
showing up and doing their absolute best
mentally emotionally physically
spiritually Etc and it got me thinking
about do you even know what your A game